Speaker 1: this is a very interesting voicemail
I received.
Our voicemail number of course is two on nine
to David P and you can call any time of day.
Here's a very specific question about a story
I have not covered and I don't know that.
I will take a listen.
Speaker 4: David.
It's Tommy.
I'm coming to you with.
Speaker 2: Tears in my eyes, sir.
You must check out the nine over ten calls
about Lauren Lopez family.
They're perfect.
Absolutely perfect.
So listen.
Speaker 1: There is this story going on where
some 911 calls.
I believe it's from radical, repugnant, reactionary
Republican Congresswoman Lauren Boebert from
her home where her neighbor called 911 because
I guess Boebert husband was going completely
crazy and like driving around and running
over people's mailboxes and just generally
acting in a completely bizarre way.
There are 911 calls that are out there.
You know, I don't have a problem covering
the personal lives of elected officials when
it is relevant to policy, like, for example,
when there is a hypocrisy between their private
lives and what they espouse.
For example, like on gay marriage, we've talked
about this or when there are double standards
of different kinds, when we are talking about
criminality in their personal lives or corruption.
I have absolutely no problem.
The fact that Boebert personal life is a mess.
And not only did her husband previously expose
himself to people in a bar or all this way,
and now he's running over mailboxes, the guy
seems to really have some issues.
Their relationship seems to be it just doesn't
really seem super relevant to the types of
things I generally cover on the show.
So I've opted not to cover the 911 call story.
I listen to some of the call over the weekend.
I don't know.
I'm curious to hear from people in the audience.
Is there a relevance to the story?
I mean, yes, her personal life is out of control.
Yes.
I wouldn't trust her to watch my cat.
And I don't even have a cat, nor do I even
like cats.
I quite frankly, I don't think much of cats.
I still, if I had one or was in charge of
one, wouldn't allow her to watch the cat.
All of that is true.
I think the woman's a moron, quite frankly.
I just don't know that the 911 calls are really
relevant to anything that we talk about on
this show.
But let me know your thoughts.
We have a fantastic bonus show today.
The situation with Salman Rushdie being attacked.
Is truly, truly a disgusting and disturbing
story.
And I've been a fan of Salman Rushdie's for
a long time, and we're going to talk about
it.
We're also going to talk about how when clinics
that offer abortions close, it's also a problem
for what's called gender affirming care.
And I'll talk to you about the connection
and the sort of vicious cycle that exists.
And lastly, Ron DeSantis has an idea.
It's a terrible idea.
His idea is, well, the teaching requirements
are too rigid in Florida to become a real
teacher.
It's too strict.
So let's figure out a way to allow veterans
with absolutely no teaching experience or
training or degrees to allow them to teach
school.
And it's a very, very bad idea, which is expected
when you're talking about Ron DeSantis.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus.
Speaker 2: Show, Pac-Man's a loser.
Speaker 1: Alex Jones doesn't like it.
I know.
And we will be doing a members only town hall
on Wednesday, August 31st, which I hope you
will participate in, and you can get access
to all of these things.
The bonus show the members only town hall
etc. by signing up at join pacman dot com.
We will see you on the bonus show or otherwise
back here tomorrow.